[Music]
today the golden gate celebrates 115
years of business it's one of the oldest
hotel casinos in downtown las vegas and
original
from the golden age hector mejia is live
in downtown las vegas to tell us how the
property is celebrating hiker good
afternoon
good afternoon we are taking a look back
in time we've seen so many properties
come and go
but not this one it's still standing
since 1906. a lot of history happened
here
on the other side of these walls the
roaring 20s prohibition
the rat pack era most recently the
coronavirus pandemic
to celebrate the golden gate's 115th
birthday ceo derek stevens
invited us over to talk about the hotel
and casino's history
even through renovations this place has
kept its vintage charms
10 original rooms are still standing and
available for visitors to sleep in
the lobby has artifacts including a
registration book
from 1907 along with a replica of the
first
phone and bottles from before the
prohibition era that were
unearthed during renovations steven says
this place
really is a step back in time
what's most important are all the
characters in here
the characters that have worked here
over the years the characters i've known
for the last 15 years
the characters who are customers that
have come in and out of the golden gate
and that's what really makes the golden
gate so special
we'll show sir a few years ago the
landmark unveiled a new expansion that
nearly doubled the casino size and added
a new entry from the fremont street
experience
and we cannot forget about this place
being famous for its 99-cent shrimp
cocktail deal
and back out here live golden gate is
just really
almost right next door to the brand new
the newest resort in town circa right
there
and here's another fun fact the golden
gate had the first telephone in town
we are told it was so new that the phone
number
was just number one reporting live on
fremont street hector mejia
we'll be back after the break